it's been nearly a year since we lost
the beautiful nya rivera and i can't
tell you how touched i was by the
extremely heartfelt post
that you shared on your instagram i just
want to ask how are you doing today
i'm good um and i i also
you know out of the utmost love and
respect for her family it's always hard
for me to even
speak about how i feel about it because
it's nowhere near
the pain that her mother her sister her
brother
her father her ex-husband her son had to
deal with and are still dealing with so
my love and respect goes out to them
above all
but i'm good you know and and uh
she's in a better place you know and and
she's chilling you know what i mean
so that is the where i can find the joy
and and the peace so yeah
yeah an amazingly talented woman um i'm
sure there's gonna be a lot of
you coming forward how do you describe
her legacy and how do you want
fans to continue to honor her i think
overall the
the amazing mother that she became and
the working mother that she became i
think she's
the the fitting image of
what women are capable of doing just as
capable as
as men are you know what i mean and she
was so strong
she was uh hilarious oh my god
um and so talented so talented
her voice always was the best i had ever
heard
truly yeah
[Music]